try you allowed to talk i'm recording by
the way are you allowed to talk about
where you are right now
no
okay cool well never mind that's fine
you might talk about that
uh i am elsewhere
hi i'm from elsewhere did you have you
ever been i have not
i had something that i wanted to talk to
you guys about today that's very because
you know we're a really trendy podcast
always does it rhyme with tony and
current it doesn't
i watch
american psycho for the first time
what oh okay and i loved it
yeah yes
i like i i did you immediately want to
go listen to huey lewis in the news
100 no it was so it was so interesting
and then i i um i looked into it like
you know the end of that movie is like
you don't know what's real and what's
not
um and so i ended up just like reading a
bunch of stuff which i love doing
whenever i watch a movie like that and
then found out that it was a female
director and i was like oh my god that
makes so much sense because there are
sex workers in that movie
none of whom are ever like grossly
sexualized and i i didn't realize it
while i was watching it but then it's
none of it's like creepy they're just
kind of there and exist and it's also
the fact that he's such a douchebag that
i was worried before watching that movie
that it ran a high risk of um glorifying
him or making him like desirable just
based on the images i had seen which the
book does a bit right the book i've not
read it but i've heard that about the
book yeah but it doesn't do that at all
he's such a [ __ ] tool
um and it it's it's good but the mia
kunis sequel is better i was just gonna
bring that up do you know that there's a
sequel to this movie it's that why
they they made us
so this is what's hilarious they made a
sequel that is not it was not shot to be
a sequel it was a movie that they
basically made a terrible thriller and
they were like what could salvage this
paradox of its day yeah is there any
like ip that we can kind of staple onto
this and sort of claim it is so they
took a movie that was 95 percent done
and definitely not at all but kind of
vaguely plot adjacent like some voice
over
they made her his sister or something
right something
yeah i never saw it i just watched like
reviews of it because i thought it just
i didn't know it existed and then it
came across randomly and and i was
watching like baffling youtuber takes on
it going this exists holy [ __ ] it's wild
and i yeah
what's it like watching a movie like
that nowadays when it's been so heavily
like memed
like do you watch it and you like are
waiting for the bits because you must
have like you must have seen so many
gifts and memes over the years from it
or does it just does it just wash over
you as a piece and say it's interesting
the first time that i watched alien um
as an adult like i didn't remember
watching it as a kid i was like alien or
aliens alien which i love probably one
of my favorite movies um but the first
time that i rewatched it i was like oh
this is so generic this looks like every
sci-fi movie and i think it might
because it was the first
and i think it might have been my dad
who was like well yeah because
everything looks like this because of
this and i was like
oh
huh um with american psycho it's a weird
curse though isn't it how things can
like age themselves out because of their
pervasive influence
i think that i had
i had very little understanding of like
i didn't know the plot i knew um
i didn't even really know scenes i don't
think i'd seen scenes i'd seen gifts
so what is the plot of american psycho
you know what i mean
i have takes on that also i really
[ __ ] enjoyed it um
why did you watch it sorry i can't keep
going why did i watch it yeah like what
what
what well i'm just curious like of all
the thousands of interrogation to choose
from like what makes you like
recommended i think on netflix or
something um and it's something that
i've wanted to watch for ages so i just
did somewhat impulsively yeah no good
reason i just wanted to watch a movie i
was like all right let's watch this um i
like how i blinked i like i blinked i
took a sip of coffee and i look up and
somehow
he teleported that's a long table i'm
always so impressed by
really long anyway uh someone's got the
game so
to your question mike
i feel like
i chicken tonight i i the movie was not
what i thought it was um
because i think that i had in my head
this is an interesting thing that
happens with classic movies like that
pulled different things from different
movies and then put them all into what i
thought american psycho was and i was
just right
it's it's a very simple story
about a man in a business and a business
card
kinda yeah
no it's about like there's definitely
themes are just like toxic competitive
nature there and i feel like the
takeaway i guess spoilers for american
psycho if you also have not seen it it's
really good 20 years yeah it's been a
while
i i really took it to mean that he did
not kill the guy he worked with he just
desperately wanted to but couldn't
wasn't in a position where he could but
that it was so inconsequential and
nobody cared and nobody even took him
seriously when he admitted to killing
the homeless and to sex workers and i
feel like that was like the point that i
took away from it was like that you know
clearly this dude's a [ __ ] douchebag
but nobody even believed him when he
confessed
i like how my video my phone
it was my phone i was watching like an
elderly version of me
it was i was watching something on
youtube and my phone occasionally it
just i'll not even be touching it the
screen will be off and it will just
occasionally randomly decide to do we
need to get you a new phone is this like
the toilet seat i'll start i've tried
yeah i like my phone including you're
the only friend that i have that have
green texts do you know what i mean yeah
all of my friends are blue you know the
funny thing is i have a i have an old
like
burner iphone uh
drug dealer like a high-class drug
dealer right yeah
why do you have it's not even
i i got it
uh so the funny thing is that a friend
of mine
uh
got really really into clubhouse and was
like you gotta check this out and i was
like i'm uh okay and i i doubt and i
look and it's not on android at the time
it was brand new it was like that week
so i was like well i guess i could get
like a super old
like what's the oldest ios
iphone that would still be able to run
it because he was really excited about
it and
then i checked it out and i was like oh
it's cool and then the phone would die
immediately because it was old and so
every time he'd be like oh i'm in this
interesting room you should come listen
i'd go the phone would be dead so i'd
have to plug it in and then by the time
it's charged it's all over i've closed
the room so yeah so i it's basically a
paperweight that's been on my desk for
six months
the drugs we would assume if somebody
has a butterfly oh no yeah i just use my
my real name for that that's that's it's
you'll be fine no one would ever believe
you that's what you say whatever you saw
i wrote [ __ ] journey the murray the
bill murray
my favorite
so there are a couple of things about
the movie that i found super interesting
the first was
initially i thought his performance was
terrible and then two scenes in i was
like oh
so at first i was like awful what the
hell is he doing did he learn to act
since this came out and then it took me
a little bit to be like oh it's because
we're watching someone pretend to be
human so we are supposed to be watching
someone who was acting the way they
think a human should act which means he
nailed it and i imagine that was very
hard
it's deeply unsettling right i remember
being really freaked out by that i
watched that movie i was a teenager it
really bothered me oh hold on
it was a nice slide
actually kind of he's a good character
he's a good guy
what are you saying you thought
that that like christian bale had
learned to act since then
yeah because you know she's saying that
was her presumption that he was
but had you ever seen
empire of the sun
no
i don't know if i've ever seen him
younger than 25. newsies
you got to watch empire because
uh my god empire the sun i wasn't alive
he's like eight in that movie and he's
guys already referred to american psycho
as a classic movie this is not a road
you want to continue down it's gonna be
bad for all of us it's time for me to
take my pills this is why the part of
the podcast when my three dads yell at
me
she's like i don't think he's six it's 2
30. i need to go to bed
yeah so i haven't seen him any anything
i think he's 25 in that movie i haven't
seen him younger than that that's the
youngest i've seen him but also
apparently everybody else on set also
thought he was a terrible actor they
thought he was awful and when they saw
it then they were like oh
which is super interesting because like
i said it's someone pretending to be
human you are watching someone pretend
to be human not someone who just is
human so it is really unsettling and
creepy and also apparently when it first
came out people
hated it like the reactions were really
people didn't know what to make of it
and i think part of that is probably
the what happens in it back then
probably would have been a little bit
more shocking i don't know but to me
there were scenes that actually really
meant to be funny that are funny
whereas i imagine if you watched it when
it came out it might have been like this
is all meant to be serious and thus is
terrifying and shocking whereas now it's
like the business card scene um which i
had not seen before is just actually
really funny it is yeah
that i think i brought that there's a
brilliant analysis i'm gonna find the
name of the guy so i can plug it but
there's a graphic design youtuber who
did like a 30 minute review of the
graphic design of those business cards
in that scene
and it's the most meta brilliant thing
around that same year another movie
that
is
hilarious and was wildly misinterpreted
and is only now seen as the classic that
it deserves to be as starship troopers
oh yeah i love stuff i watched that over
the weekend weird coincidence
linus bowman by the way the graphic
design youtuber who did uh it's a
15-minute deep dive of the graphic
design of the business cards and why
every word they use is wrong and like
pointing out that in itself is a funny
joke for those that's amazing that's
wrong they're full of graphic design
jokes
man starship troopers is really
interesting to watch nowadays
it's kind of loops back into just being
pure comedy now like it was satirical
when it came out but now it's not
supposed to be funny
it was always seen as satirical yeah but
i think now it's like it feels like a
broad comedy now watching it in a way
that i don't remember it feeling
10 years ago
uh maybe i'll scroll well i don't know
that i would ever go so far as to call
it broad comedy but i just think that
people were so
distracted by the violence and first off
ignoring the fact that the violence is
part of the joke but also the the
the
spectacle because it's one of those
movies that sort of
manages to also be a pretty massive feat
of production like it was a huge budget
ridiculous real like really really high
end visual effects and i remember
there's a shot in that movie i mean i
feel like i'm getting a deja vu i may
have talked about this here before but
the
there's a shot where they have like
uh bombers come in and strafe the desert
and set off and you know drop all these
explosives and they did that they went
out into the desert somewhere and did
that as a practical effect where they
they had a bunch of explosive charges
all in a row and at the time and maybe
still since things are so little so
rarely practical now it had the
guinness record of the of the single
like longest continuous
practical explosion shot in any movie
wow so it's like the movie's full of
these kind of just
outrageous achievement and the fact that
the cg holds up as well as it does for a
movie that's 20 years old is for those
jurassic park team right wasn't it the
next thing the jurassic park team went
and did so it's those same islands i
think it is i think it's the same the
same group that would make sense
because they crashed yeah they kind of
because it is if you look i watched yeah
jurassic park i also watched the weekend
where they had a really good blockbuster
movie weekend clearly but jurassic park
jurassic park is starting to age like
jurassic park it feels like forever it's
been holding up and now the cg you're
just starting to see like the seams on
it in a way that feels very
that we've moved on just enough that
that's now a thing i'll tell you
speaking of that
this is not going to be like a popular
blockbuster uh i also just watched
constantine the keanu reeves constantine
that's awesome
that's a fun movie
yeah it was not the impression that it
was terrible and then i watched it and i
was like good time
yeah i thought it was terri this is the
first time i've heard it praised i i
always didn't bother because i thought
it was sort of it could be my
expectations a little ahead of its time
i think little i think the audience were
wanting like a sillier movie i think
it's a i think we're now more accepting
of comic book movies being a bit more
interesting i think especially because
it would be in the dcu
people would be like oh my god this is
great that's true
finally
but actually
and then there's characters that's great
yeah characters are consistent yeah um
it's uh i i i do like uh the tv version
of it better i think that uh that was
great fun yeah matt was a far closer
version of like he looked like he walked
out the graphic novel um keanu reeves
fun actor as well right like
he was here in black flag yes was he he
was protecting some black flag as well
right no no i think that's the same
actor yeah i think so welsh fellow yep
he's welsh he's great i'm in agreement
playing liverpudlian of course because
constantine is constantly never paddling
yeah i think that's right yeah
to americans that's like 40 miles down
the road so like i appreciate that to
americans that sounds like the same
accent but it's very importantly
different yeah i i wondered if uh
because yeah the reviews were so bad and
i had always had it in my head that it
was terrible that when i watched it i
wondered if
if exactly what you've just touched on
might be the case like it's not like it
was a perfect movie but i enjoyed it way
more than i expected to um some really
cool choices and i was like is this
maybe because when it existed we weren't
accepting of the comic book movie format
and now that i'm so used to this format
this exists in that
as i would say one of the better ones
and there was also some really good cg
it's actually aged quite well and some
cool practical effects but it's not like
i think it was
it was also genuinely disturbing like it
there were moments and there was like
[ __ ] not like serpent in the rainbow but
it was definitely it was haunting
yeah random i think we all get yeah i
did not see that one going
i think people are more in tune with
keanu reeves than they were in that
period that was very much the period
where it was cool to hate on him
and now we get it you know it was after
like the walk in the clouds and what
what is he a teen is he a heartthrob
what is he doing he's like he just needs
to go away for a second and then he's
going to come back he's going to do
matrix and then we're going to goof on
him and then he's going to do john wick
would be like oh my god i think oh i
didn't realize he went through that kind
of cycle
oh keanu reeves was like has gone
through periods where people absolutely
hate him no way in my head he's like
yeah i'm kind of pop culture he was a
punchline for a lot of noises despite
doing excellent work like he didn't feel
like point break was the first one like
first window of looking down on him
hmm i think is he always played a range
of roles he was willing to be stupid on
camera i think which is which is death
if you're good-looking there was also a
period of his life where there was a
little bit of a substance issue so like
he was he was kind of bombing his like
uh going all the way back to bill and
ted's excellent adventure two where he
almost got fired from set because he was
just [ __ ] off no i didn't know that
and he got his [ __ ] together
and
but like that yeah you're like point
break to where it was like are you an
action star
and then it was like well what if we
turn you into like the romantic drama
person and then there was just like some
really bad versions of that like the
post box or whatever the [ __ ] it's
called where they communicated to each
other via a portal in time
house lake house
body of water slash above something
um and and then like body of water abode
that was the working title
that was the work title what you do is
you always get to protect the
pretentious writer they're going to put
a name like that but it really takes a
hollywood they can learn a new word
they'll look it up they'll be smarter
for it
um
you know i had that happen i had that i
did
one of the best movies i've ever scored
was called the grief tourist
and the distributor
the distributor
uh
made them change the name because they
go nobody knows the word grief and if
you go and look it up it's literally
shipped as the dark tourist which is
uh seriously stupid
doctors isn't existing i've seen that
seriously
well this was more than 10 years ago but
it
but like in the movie he uses the term
grief tourists because the whole pr
principle of a grief tourist is somebody
who
like whereas some people go to you know
the grand canyon or visit the empire
state building other people go to like
the grassy knoll and
ground zero and
you know 911 yeah places of places where
something horrendous has happened and
those are grief tourists and it's like a
kind of a niche subculture you know and
the movie follows this guy who's kind of
it's so it's so good it's kind of a sort
of a taxi driver type like unhinged
personality kind of movie michael
cudlitz from bannon brothers is the lead
and uh he's [ __ ] amazing it starts
off with one of my favorite opening
scenes where over black you just hear
this
and it just goes and goes and goes as
they do the first initial credits and
then it cuts and you see him and he's in
this at a little card table in this
really dingy apartment like very small
and he's just endlessly pouring uh salt
onto a plate and then he takes a
hard-boiled egg and he rolls it back and
forth and the salt puts the whole egg in
his mouth and then takes a drag on a
cigarette with it before he's even
chewed on it that's like how you meet
his character
and it's so [ __ ] memorable and he's
so good and um
and then yeah they released it as the
dark tourist which made it look like
some
you know like american psycho two you
know it just looks like a straight to
dvd like what the [ __ ] is this and it's
such a shame because such a good movie
and they yeah the premise was people
don't know the word grief that's sad
like the kind of people that are going
to see this movie are going to know that
like this is not a 5 000 screen opening
weekend movie we can accept that wild oh
you're not kidding the box art for it
really looks like it's terrible single
straight dvd what did you look up the
doctoris movie
yeah i was looking at the duck tourist
that's the sequel to howard the duck
underrated
uh yeah
no it's it's it's such a shame he's a
good actor as well that guy i like him
yeah
howard the duck yeah that was adapting
he was just that's just him just him
like auditions like you got it is this
one
dark tourist
dark tourism
yeah the one there yeah they had to
feature melanie griffith
that second one you showed is the more
common one that i've seen there's just a
lot of a lot of sadness in that sentence
they had to feature melanie griffith no
they're always gonna it's like i did a
movie once that had uh that had uh
cranston and ron livingston but they
were small parts and and
and that's how they got their
distribution they put
well i should say they have limited
screen time then uh
they're great in it actually but they're
not the stars of the of the film but of
course the the people doing the dvd were
like we're gonna go ahead and this was
like at the height of breaking bad's
popularity like middle of the middle of
their run you know well actually the
height was i guess the end of it but it
was going full steam and everyone was
like let's put cranston in the center of
the so everyone will be disappointed
when they watch this movie and discover
he's in the first and last three minutes
of the movie i'm surprised that you're
allowed to do that that there isn't some
law against zilla did it they were like
do you mind showing up for 20 minutes
like yeah i've got them on my lunch
breaks like we might have filming our
movies like yeah yeah there's an entire
scream franchise is built on this
premise isn't it it's
like that's yeah with who is the joke
when i
uh scream yeah but like who spoilers
that's i mean there's the joke with the
poster of every scream movie that i
don't want to spoil for anyone who's not
seen scream wait the original or the one
that just came out ongoing repeatedly
i've not seen that i've not seen the new
ones i don't know but i would i would
guess they do the same jokes in every
single movie i feel like i don't know
what you're talking about
okay spoilers for the screen franchise i
guess quickly
jump on five minutes every scream movie
um one of the people on the box art or
poster is killed in the first two
minutes they die yeah
they they kill real quick
so it's like jada pinkett smith and the
second one drew barrymore in the first i
can't remember who's in the third
you should somewhat be able to do that
but at the start they're like the
protagonist i had to think they set them
up as the protagonist this is like the
psycho
you know that was i think that's the
first movie that did that right where
they took like the super famous movie
star and it was hated at the time
because of it right was it like hitch
yeah they were like we know who janet
lee is we have no clue
who uh oh my god i'm drawing a blanket's
name
um i don't play norman bates oh uh
norman bates
oh my goodness this isn't fair
remembering the name of the actor i
can't remember either
rod um
oh my god i got you
thank you anthony perkins anthony
perkins that's right uh nobody directed
who he was
and so all of a sudden just like that
movie unless you like i mean everyone
watching that movie now
has you know knows the shower scene
right like they've you that's just pop
culture whereas
you know all the people who went to see
that movie look at the poster look at
what it was like everyone who saw that
movie was not expecting the protagonist
of the story to not make it through
halfway through the movie like that's
now you watch it and you're waiting for
it you know it's coming right like what
kubrick did for for like the shining and
stuff towards like
let's just start there let's just kind
of like as quickly as we can get people
in there and and
psycho lingers in the city for a long
time yeah it's just a it's a heist movie
or a kind of a kind of a slice of life
stealing she's she's stolen from her
work hasn't she right she's yeah she's
like a courier who they ask her to go
deliver it to the bank or whatever and
then she just decides or not it reminds
me i watched um i remember as a teenager
talking my dad um into watching um
oh god i've got the name um
uh rodriguez vampire movie
oh from dusk
until they get to the street club but i
did so i i was like oh from dusk till
dawn that's it's i was teenage dumb
teenager i was like i think it's like a
tarantino vampire movie and my dad likes
old horror movies so it's like i'll
watch a vampire movie yeah let's do it
and we watched for like half an hour and
he's like this is just a gangster film
like i don't know what the vampire so he
go he went off to bed and then obviously
like as a 13 year old i wonder what he
bailed most
yeah exactly he was like this is just a
weird gangster movie with tarantino
playing like a really sketchy guy mike
this is my kind of thing and i went away
and then of course suddenly then it
suddenly goes full vampire are you
traumatized
massively like as a teenager by that
film yeah that really it was the guitar
it was the guitar
george bunny is so good he was it was a
masterpiece but plant yourself on the
couch i don't know what you i said plant
yourself plants don't talk
amazing i got six little friends and
they can all run faster than you if you
they uh don't think i might see rule
number one but like my favorite thing
that tarantino did in that movie
is i'm sorry robert oregano movie was
like nothing tarantula does in that
movie is something you want some of them
no
he
steals
the horror of what
his brother did
off of clooney's expression he has one
flash of it and all clues he says is
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
it's just so good and like dennis hopper
no no no no dennis hopper jesus christ
what is wrong with my brain uh i don't
um um what's his name cousins right is
yeah that's the only role that i enjoy
having harvey keitel in
um he's great yeah he's
got to sit
that's the explosion of salma hayek in
the popular consciousness is that film
it makes it look like from all the
screenshots that i can see that
tarantino is is he in this movie like a
lot like he's a yeah he's a protagonist
oh interesting it's clooney he's like
he's terrible
right yeah yeah yeah and he they play
brothers
that are bank robbers which is the most
generous casting of tarantino possibly
do yeah yeah you're gonna be playing
george clooney's brother i mean i think
that might be a football too which is
very tarantino of him
i think he's oh he's maybe something on
his face oh oh oh oh oh oh that was that
word
from her foot yeah it's it's like
it's two movies in one and all of a
sudden it just goes turn and then it
goes romp as i'll see it it's amazing
there's also a second movie yeah from
just on two not good oh okay i um
yeah i think this podcast should just
become a show where we recommend 90s
movies
i did consider for a while because they
used to do it to me at fun house all the
time i've not seen time cup i did
consider doing a series where i
re-review old movies
um but it's much more fun to me to just
talk to friends about them because i
feel like people have such strong
opinions on movies that it wouldn't
actually be fun for me whereas like if
it's something or i'm exploring movies i
haven't seen it i'm enjoying it i think
that like doing it on youtube would just
be people screaming at me like i didn't
like scarface or i did but i thought it
was overrated and i was like the amount
of people who just get mad at me for
saying that like i don't know that i
need to take away this fun thing i'm
doing hold on i think this is another
alien situation where it's
it's not overrated it's just so many
movies have now taken from that that
wasn't my issue though it was there
it i didn't feel like it had any
substance and it was very stylish but i
expected it to say something or mean
something i can't even have a kid or a
woman
his that's depalma's kind of my favorite
line is a white piece of bread i think
that's a great insult because someone a
white piece of breath um but i don't i
didn't i just didn't i think in my head
which is like in could entirely be what
i've done um is i pictured it making
some kind of statement because the way
people talk about it and i didn't feel
like it made one i felt like it was
stylish and and that's it the story was
great music but i was like yeah you
didn't leave me with anything the story
was great it's all about the character
sure
and and that's that to me is what 70s
movies were all about like watch watch
dog day afternoon what's what's
you should really owe it to yourself to
watch the progression of al pacino so
that's part of the problem is that i
watched it right after watching the
godfather one and two and i was like oh
my god i get it these movies are
incredible holy [ __ ] these these are
amazing i see what they're saying it's
so interesting and then i watched
scarface and i had that yeah but that's
too big of a jump and i was like okay
godfather i get why everybody loves
scarface
you gotta go godfather dog day afternoon
serpaco
then do like like jump into because that
like by 1979
i don't know what you expected me to do
i told my pacino story on the show
no i think so
probably not so i've i have a pacino
story i was i was sat in this when we
were doing john wick i was sat in a
really nice vegan restaurant called
actually i won't say what it is just in
case he goes there regularly i don't
wanna help the guy is this the one we
went to
no this is different one this is in l.a
um so
at a lovely restaurant you have told
this story have i i can stop then this
is this is very well no i mean obviously
we've got like 93
philadelphia podcast in every single
episode is one of them started telling a
story everyone's saying you've told that
story they're worried about
anyway i'll cut it short i accidentally
gave crashed al pacino's like 80th
birthday party and he was amazing and he
did hoo-ha's for the entire room because
he was lovely you know what i sat next
to her every time a few months ago you
sent me something i saw his lap i think
it's a who ah not
yeah we uh were at an italian restaurant
in la last year and he was seated
directly behind me on like a booth seat
so every time
i kept being very annoyed i kept being
like oh [ __ ] this guy behind me just
keeps [ __ ] moving all the time
readjusting oh i'm so sorry
i'm over the table
oh god he's he's an incredible actor
it's
tracy tracy i think he's he's a very big
actor but i think he's one of those
actors who for me showcases he's an
actor who showcases great direction
because when he's directed well he's the
best and when he's not he he can go a
little bit all over the place it's
understanding the transition from like
because you gotta this person who shows
up in godfather one and he sucks and
he's so demure and like reserved and
then you can see coppola going hold it
uh bye austin
austin's like i will not hear alpha
cheetos slandered i don't know why that
happened it wasn't like he disconnected
no maybe he got maybe he got upset
because i was i was trashing him for
dick tracy
maybe that's what it was wasn't it
welcome back austin you got upset
because i was trashing dick tracy
[Music]
so but but i have no explanation for
what just happened because you could see
coppola being other than my fault hold
off and and and we're going to get to
that moment where he turns and then
godfather two holy [ __ ] is incredible
but the
the uh the dog day afternoon is where
you start seeing is like what what
happens if this guy goes unhinged and
then serpico is really where it starts
like get loud i want to see how if you
can get loud so by the time you get to
like scarface and and then sin of a
woman is another like milestone where
it's like
you want an oscar for that
but it's it's definitely like
you're now a characterized version of
yourself and people are going to know
you for being loud but if you were to go
back to godfather it's like
that the moment with apollonia is just
like
ugh
so good
you haven't seen
very very so speaking of robert
rodriguez
we were
speaking of melanie griffith how about
that bungie acquisition am i right i was
gonna bring up books
oh yeah you can talk about why i'm not
watching it
i was curious because when it when we
did like a drive-by like we finished one
a few weeks ago and alana you were like
i'm not really liking it okay bye and
the episode but it was after only the
first episode and now i think there's
been five of them and i'm curious have
you have you troy you just said no
yeah does this look like a funny chair
is that your way of saying
don't talk about boba fett
i
i don't know if you guys would feel this
way but like there's so much stuff to
watch right now and i'm surprised
yeah there's just so much of all of it
to watch and i you know what i'm
watching right now this is so dorky
arcane
no don't
that's ten comments just by saying that
they comment every week about it
um
and by the way just you guys know
we won't talk about it until you stop
commenting
[Laughter]
we're [ __ ] pretentious five years too
late we're topic
um so mike finally got around to playing
last month
a different character it's a whole
different thing
i like loaded up there's stuff that's
like i'm feeling that like that the the
covet production wave
hit because there's there's all these
shows that are finally coming back now
because you know like she took huge
hiatuses from kobed like billions is
back i was like i don't [ __ ] remember
anything and there's so much stuff that
i've i've watched we just went through
ozark um which is just bravo so good
um but like i have all these shows
loaded up and i
i can't i can't find myself like
starting them like if i feel weird like
if you ever finished a good book and
then you're like i don't want to start
another one because empty afterwards
yeah yeah you're sad that it's over yeah
yeah so i've been watching poker i went
back and watched like the 2003 and the
2004 world series because it was just
such an iconic moment in in like it
sounds super dorky but
no i've been so i've been meaning to get
into watching poker is there like is
there a specific place i should start
then is there like uh like absolutely
awesome yes here's what you need to
understand here do it because i watched
i've been getting into poker and i want
to watch like some some like
pro levels to understand where poker is
now and it's hit its peak and and has
really kind of died off but this isn't
what i expected
london's face go for it though just go
ahead
i know i really i genuinely want the
intro i want to know why should like
where i should start okay in 2003
in 1970 was the first world series of
poker and six people entered six people
in 2003 600 people entered into it
it all came down to
four people essentially um phil ivey sam
farhad johnny chan and this new guy
chris bunnymaker the other three guys
are professionals everybody knew who
they were they had one world series of
pokers before they won bracelets they're
big deals and one by one this guy chris
moneymaker knocked them all out
including sam farha to win should have
known from the name really that was a
saving for our house
i wouldn't sit down with someone called
money maker that's
he was his nickname was dead money
because he had never he was called money
maker and he had a nickname
yeah
his real name is money maker and they're
like he's not a money maker he's dead
money
right so
uh
uh chad norman i think gave him that
name or llama karen did anyway
um he had never sat down in a live game
before meaning he had never actually sat
down at a table in a casino with other
human beings he had only played online
and it was it was
after that like 2000 that's 2003 600
people
um signed up in 2004
over 2500 people
signed up they couldn't fit they had to
move you opened up the sport it made it
feel like something anyone could kind of
come in and try now all of a sudden
we've got this major sport cameras are
coming in now we're here
go ahead yes um uh sorry how many people
was that on the
um 600 in 2003 and there was 25 over
2500 people in taking notes this is not
going to be on the final yeah taking
notes oh no there's just a [ __ ]
blinding light it's just real bright it
just got real bright you look like
powder right now
it's kind of scary
i don't care for it
[Laughter]
lance henriksen what else could you want
um
something something without you know
anyway we'll give the controversy of
that film
um but it's it's it's a it's an
incredible sport and it's a it's a
wonderful insight into um
people like culture and how to relate to
other humans i think poker is fantastic
i remember that big explosion happened
when i was in college because that was
we played it in our we like our little
our little apartment of
the six of us we played there was this
period where
texas hold'em was the nightly tradition
for
months and months and months just every
night for hours
and that because it was like that was
the time where those oh everything that
you're describing i'd forgotten all
those names but this was very much when
that was the thing and everybody had to
do it all of them i mean like dana
mcgrawn and chris ferguson uh doyle
brunson like i'm dutch boyd and phil
hellmuth i knew all these guys these it
was the only sport like as people are
like football or or proper football
soccer um
baseball like they can name like
all the people who did this i could do
that with poker that was that was my
thing yeah
um
but the uh if you want to watch a really
really good movie um that hit just
before the poker movie came out 2001
it's called rounders with matt damon and
ed norton that was what got me into i
watched it about two weeks ago why am i
watching all these relevant movies this
is becoming the new bookshelf mike's
watched every movie that's gonna come up
organically in conversation but yeah
that's his great film he says rolled up
bases over kings
check's so hike can see over him ed
norton is so good my family has uh like
a sort of uh i don't know if i've said
this on the podcast before history with
poker and that um my uncle was
associated with opening the first ever
casino in australia
um so i i could play blackjack from when
i was like 12. and uh poker from when i
was you know 13 14 and so there was one
time where uh i
invited people from my school over for a
poker night and had everybody put in
real money though i didn't know that i
would be so much better at it than
everybody else and just you just felted
your friends that was the only one
the four of us are in vegas three weeks
from now
yeah
i stopped playing
three of us it's like it could have been
a pokemon
troy
stuff yeah i'm shooting so i that's i
have to cancel my hotel room
unless i call you guys it's like hey a
hooked up with a killer we're waking up
to the hotel room
to figure out a way for us to film
something in the same room
when is that we should try it's the uh
25th i think
dice is no 25
yeah 24th 24th i think sorry i was you
had to correct me there austin because i
was a day off it's about hotel rooms
that accuracy of a day matters
um
but in any case yeah so i could have
like grown up to be like a
poker prodigy my my um uncle and my aunt
had this like gold card that i've always
been meaning to now that i'm an adult
ask them more about where they could
just go anywhere they wanted in vegas
anywhere they wanted they had this card
that anywhere would let them in and give
them an amazing room because they were
in the casino industry um and i i
you know went to a casino on my 18th
birthday as soon as i was allowed to but
then i stopped because
of the amount of people that even by
proximity to that i saw ruin their lives
um like
just completely ruin their lives in a
way that just
like even in the first month of of being
around it or just like people pissing
themselves playing poker machines while
they're losing their money just still
sitting in the seats that i was just
like i just
sucks to watch that said
now i've always wanted to do it with
friends like have a group poker thing i
just don't want to do it at a casino
i just i can't let myself do that
because i whatever part of your brain
people who get addicted to gambling have
i have that like i whenever i sit down
and do anything involving gambling money
i get too into it and it's one of those
ones where it's like no never going to
go near that again that's uh that's me
with mmos
i can't plan mmo all right it's going to
ruin me for months can't do it yep
definitely playing an mmo is definitely
getting on the wagon for me totally that
is the thing i have to commit to knowing
i will do nothing else
it would be really cool if we can do an
in-person thing for dice though and i
feel like this is a good time to bring
up that we are going to start recording
the podcast due to uh the schedules of
the the two men who are on the bottom
from my perspective um
am i one of those men
i don't like being referred to it's not
one of the two
like
men
i'll
be
perspective does it look like our
microphones go into like a portal to
each other
no that would be cool though if we
flipped austin
then maybe
no it's troy
there we go i'm trying to help you but
now the mic's not in shot so close um
the i can you guys talk about what
you're working on that will take you out
of action no okay so uh the two of them
are busy so we're gonna drop back to
every second week for the time being i
only think it needs to be a few
instances of that it's a short term
yeah at most i i just i just know it's
it's a particularly it's and the funny
thing is it's not that it's
been 24
7 stuff it's just this window of time is
consistently an issue
uh oh i can guess why that makes sense
and yeah so it's like it it i just
realized look i saw the consequences of
missing one episode i don't want to miss
anymore so i would rather just lift i
would rather just limit the number of
episodes
rather than you miss and we replace you
with different composers like it's very
easy to forget that this did start as a
monthly podcast yeah
i'd like to point out that not only me
as well i'm gonna be i'm gonna be having
to
kind of not be here for more episodes
i'm fine it's just gonna happen we're
gonna we're gonna evolve the show but
it's happening to us
not only was it once a month to start
but the first episode is all fallen
order b-roll because our video didn't
yeah i know yeah so we had a we had an
excellent start we've got to have the
amateur first episode on the podcast
that's essential
i'm gonna left turn once again since my
boba fett left turn was coming no i
would like to talk about boba fett i
really would
it's just fascinating to me i think it's
terrible
it's not terrible but it is interesting
how they accidentally made boba fett
already uh with a new with a made-up
character that they invented and then
now they have to go to the source and
they're like oh [ __ ] what do we do
it's interesting there's things i like
about it but it's also it's also odd
nothing happening i don't like the way
it's shot i think it's just yeah the
characters are just really boring
um there's a suggestion of badassery but
no like actual badassery and then logic
leaps like the coolest part for me was
sarlacc pit related and then i was like
but why do you need to go that doesn't
make any sense you you already dealt
with that i don't understand oh was it
after jedi
danny trejo have i told my danny trejo
story no
i
like i went to la with uh my producer
again during john wick time and by weird
coincidence we kept going past signs for
danny trejo's chain of restaurants right
he's going in la there's a few of them
we just kept ending up by danny trejo
restaurants and it became a running joke
throughout the day that i wanted to go
to danny trejo restaurant that night
because i wanted to see danny trejo and
i was just like doing you know the act
of the petulant child i would go daddy
trevor's restaurant i'll see danny trejo
and we the whole day that was just a
running gag in and out of professional
business meetings with me mouthing i
want to see daddy treyo to my producer
while he's trying to pitch people on
things
he really is just we went to i was
waiting for the people to look away from
me so i could do it and then end of the
day we went to the restaurant one day
trails chain of restaurants and danny
trejo walked in and it was doing the
books basically next to us he's actually
like involved in the running of that
business
it's just the best thing it's amazing
that is he's incredibly
uh kind and gentle
like amazing just seems like a lovely
bloke yeah yeah 100
what danny trejo
you definitely
yes
funny enough the boba fett thing was a
bail on that but i i um a game that i
have heard nobody recommend to me but i
was a huge fan of uh when it when the
first one came out 20 years ago as a
long-running rts fan
um i can spell thank you
and i i randomly tried uh well not
randomly but part of dice stuff i played
recently and i was like this is awesome
why is no one talking about is age of
empires four
uh i that's a
is that the new one
it's a new one and i don't know if this
is something that franchise has been
doing because i played the first one and
not since since i don't think i've
played any since the newest one
um
but it's like a playable history
documentary where in between like the
campaigns go through actual like the
mongolian expansion into
into russia or or you know the 100 years
war where every mission the campaign is
a historic battle and they they actually
went so far as to go to the real
locations and film and then like cgi
wireframes of the old soldiers which
seems like it would be really cheesy but
i was watching and i was like this is
honestly
this makes it a thousand times more
interesting to then play through the
campaign that that they are
trying to step you through things that
really happen and then they give you
like you know joan of arc is now a
playable character because she was
instrumental in this battle in the 100
like and i just found myself really cool
i was like
i didn't needed i played it it ran a
friend of mine worked on the music and i
was also playing it as part of the
jury for dice and i was like
i found myself just once the thing was
over i just kind of went back to it and
kept playing and and played through the
whole thing and i was like this is
this is so funny that this one has
completely escaped notice and it's a
it's a big franchise i played a demo and
i really enjoyed it
very nostalgic for it like i loved age
of empires as a kid but i'm so bad at
rts's i'm just terrible at them
that if it's if it's a campaign that
like heads you in a direction i'll have
a an easier time with it it definitely
does because it's it's literally like
it's really cool it's built it really
felt like
there's so few games that you could
describe as playable documentary where
they're aspiring to actually step you
through real things yeah um remember
there was an indicate game that someone
made about like i'm trying to remember
what it was but it was a specific
brazilian tradition that they felt was
starting to die off and they they wanted
to make a game that honored these things
that served as kind of like a living yes
i remember talking about and that was
cool too it was like the hot air
balloons
yeah it was a beautiful idea of of like
games to serve as a
as an alternative to documentaries and i
just i don't know it's working soft has
been doing that lately um where at least
they did it i think maybe starting with
the origins but i think they've also
done it with assassin's creed odyssey
where there is like an exploration
position or whatever yeah that has
educational purposes that uh some people
have been using in schools
did you know the the coolest thing on
origins was
uh
is it origins that was the one right
before egypt right after black flag no
okay yeah what's the what was the french
syndicate
i'm familiar with syndicate
unity was the one
unity apparently
for purposes of unity they i think feel
like i'm having another deja vu they so
accurately
uh
recreated a 3d model of the notre dame
for that game that when it was on fire
yes they used the like model to better
direct the firefighters because it was
like a far more accurate representation
of it or something like that yeah so
that's that's one of those unfortunately
i'm going to be the nerd is that not a
true story it's utter bollocks yeah it
was like uh it was really yeah it's one
of those urban legends yeah it was it's
because it's not actually not the
because all of the buildings in
assassin's creed are actually like much
smaller than they are in real life like
obviously to make no you just scale them
up
you just go you just go scale when i
fail
like me like me you treat it like me yes
is it
in the getaway like everything was a
one-to-one and like people could like
yeah
it was pretty good you could use i
remember as a teenager when i was going
on like a school trip to london i
remember like me and my mate would like
play
the getaway at home to work out the
route we were going to be taking and
stuff but it was relatively such a good
game man i loved
navigate uh parts of paris because of
midtown madness
i was like oh i know where this is in
proximity to this because of midtown
madness i played on xbox when i was 10.
i was at lax and was at a certain part
of lax i'd never been to before was like
the only reason i know this exists is
because gta totally being i've been on
this road before wild when you first go
and like i was like
i've done skateboard tricks on that um
what the hell well you turn
you go to los santos and you take a left
you can't see it it's like i remember
when uh insomniac spider-man came out in
that same vein i tried to go to the
exact corner that i had lived at in
manhattan and that's how i discovered
that they cheat that game because all
the numbered streets go every other
street so it's like 2nd street 4th
street you know you know and then the i
think the avenues is actually
closer to accurate but manhattan i was
i'm pretty sure there's actually half
the number of streets of real manhattan
to make the map more manageable because
the actual intersection that i was
trying to find uh didn't exist but it
was very close to the avengers tower
apparently which was exciting i wish
there was more
um like design conversation around the
the skill and the art in open world
games of how you edit a city to make it
interesting as a game space totally like
it's just not something either noise
yeah
like it's really there's an amazing
somewhere there are designers who really
yeah
is that because it's too realistic it's
empty it could be because it's a reality
it's empty it was pretty damn
accurate to i just remember again that
was the apartment i was living in when
that game came out
was just off the map and it i was so
infuriated because i remember i was so
excited because i remember thinking this
is so
accurate and there were so many like
photo historic photos that you could one
to one with all of a million locations
watchdogs legion was pretty i remember
watch dogs legion my my my my flat was
my then flat i was living in was like
just outside the map and i was
heartbroken i had raffle give me a tour
of watchdog's legion as a londoner and
um
like direct meter like where he had
performed on stage or whatever and ended
up just with people being furious at him
for like forgetting directions and part
of it was because he was like because
you just take the tube and london
everybody just goes underground i don't
[ __ ] know what this is above ground i
had the same exact thing we did a race
to see who could um
scale uh
or get to big ben faster and either
watch dogs legion or um syndicate
assassin's creed syndicate and so we
started from the same place
and it was it was hilarious but i i was
like i'm going to win because i had
victoria adkin who's a londoner she's
like oh [ __ ] no
she's like you get on the waterloo
station island
i remember the first time when i was
living in london i actually had to walk
across london i can't remember why like
i just didn't want anybody or something
and realizing how close everything was
because i was used to like you say that
kind of that island thing of just like
oh wow so much more walkable than these
places people think yeah
everything is a half mile from each
other
yeah if you're in if you live in london
as i did and you use the tube for
everything just try and walk between two
landmarks it's mind-blowing you're like
this feels like a theme park because
you're like it's all all of the parks
are connected and it's
what i found interesting was that the
term subway we in america use it
incorrectly a subway sandwiches yeah yes
[Laughter]
that was quick
um
you walk through under so you walk
underneath it
that's so that's why people walk under
the street is a subway and then the tube
is for
the transients yeah yeah uh there's an
interesting uh uh uh i guess a designer
on halo infinite did a thread about
how they approached
designing some of the because that is
more of an open world than any halo game
prior or anything that 343 has worked on
prior
how he went about like making just some
areas of the map look more interesting
and uh he was telling stories is what he
decided to do um was basically like okay
so i've decided that like this is an
encampment that the unsc would have been
using for training for this kind of
weapon so i'm gonna leave these weapons
here or like oh these ones maybe one of
them got hit by a grenade so there's a
med pack to like make sure that all of
those little set pieces that people just
kind of gloss over when they're playing
through is that someone like actually
sat down in person and personally
intimately designed it it's a really
is actually dying but she's lived a good
life so this is like just heaven's like
kind of she's off now it's fine how nice
is the final act oh there's even a
little bit of lots of your hair back i
feel wow
wow my thing just came out and said
playing music set up professional audio
in audio settings thank you zoom for
thinking that i was playing professional
music with my heart because you did that
that is very nice yeah look at you guys
how to tell us you are using a new
computer without telling us you're using
a new computer it does that to me
sometimes just randomly does whatever it
wants to that point of the kind of
environmental art i was just talking to
someone this week about how when i first
played the old uh
warren spector original deus ex one of
my absolute favorite things
one of my absolute favorite things
obviously he takes credit for all of it
more inspector like that sorry carry on
the the all the like computers that you
can hack that have the world's most
mundane email threads on them there's
just like thousands some writers had to
write like literally thousands of emails
of you know hey uh i saw you like the
boss emailing the employee going you
know you came in late from lunch uh
three days this week and so you know
we're gonna have to you're gonna have to
keep a closer eye on that or what like
just because one out of ten will have
like a password on it that say oh the
janitor closet now is this and we're
keeping some equipment in there and
that's like how you can find how to get
weapons or whatever but just the sheer
amount of real world
noise it exists in that i've always
thought was so
amazing as a kind of immersion
technique just to to make it not feel
like it's some placeholder graphic but
it's actually a thing you can touch and
it has stuff it has content
because there's absolutely decision
making that goes into that have any of
you played quantum break
yeah yeah so i actually really enjoyed
that game i had a fun time with it um
and there's this thing did you do the
other content though like did you also
watch the tv show yeah you have to don't
you
well
i did at least like i sat through it um
but like that i was watching the stuff
that was playing real time
so i i play that game episodically
basically where i play however
gameplay the gameplay and watch the tv
show bit and then much
show a bit um and i i really enjoyed it
i had a great time with it um but it has
this thing in it called uh it's a it's a
screenplay called time knife that you
can find i believe it's on somebody's
computers right um and it is
a terrible screenplay and it's it's
super funny because i was getting
through this game that has like a bunch
of serious themes you know it's remedy
where i'm excited every time that i find
a new act of the time knife um and i
looked it up to see like where you can
find it so it i think there's
five acts
and uh the first line is bruce savage a
sexually attractive man is standing in
his office when the scientist lady who
looks like a librarian but is actually a
scientist enters his office and asks for
help and it sounds like a peter griffin
version of a story kinda that's such a
remedy it was also really really really
really good that they like just have
this shitty screenplay that somebody in
these buildings is working on that
you're watching or you can find all the
acts of and put it together it's it's
really funny and it's like that's such
an unnecessary thing to do but i'm so
glad if you work on this stuff if you if
you work in games and you do stuff like
that just know that there are people
like us that care and we appreciate we
love you all that i've had to do like
for ghostbusters i had to do i did like
80 of the um
voicemails left for the ghostbusters
just in case you happen to check the
messages
um
you would get
majority of the time me
yeah
that means people appreciate it for sure
speaking of assassin's creed that's
available for the switch today isn't it
is it
the the the seo collection or whatever
oh the seo stuff
i wouldn't mind going back i brought my
i didn't bring my playstation but i did
bring my switch and my um my oculus hell
yeah good stuff there so i've got an
arcade camera
in the background of the shot
brought the whole arcade cabinet i have
to run feel free to continue hanging out
amongst yourselves but i haven't
realized
i do also have to run um so yeah we
won't have an episode next week but we
will have one the week after and we'll
continue that and i will just update
everybody as that changes if it changes
and maybe we'll try and figure out how
to do something in person for dice if we
can
very cool can we yeah i'll bring up i'll
bring a um
a body pillow uh and and uh strap a ipad
to like the top of it and i was going to
say i actually already have a troy baker
branded body pillow exactly yeah i'll
thank you he sent you one as well right
that wasn't just me okay
you can only get into japan but it's
worth the [ __ ] um
listen everybody i'm a lot of video
gamers that's also injured he's a video
game composer that's rebecca's video
actor that is mike bethel he's a video
game director
see you next week